mike on va faire un petit vrai-faux sur
mike horn et après bien sûr je serai on
va revenir
la dernière expo dit les expéditions de
mike tu as on a plein de choses à la
feuillade et bien sûr là dessus alors
vrai faux sur mike horn on va voir si
vous le connaissez bien parce que c'est
des trucs incroyables plus tard était
vrai ou faux à seulement huit ans mike a
fait 300 km de vélo pour rejoindre la
ferme de son oncle alors il a fait comme
ça ils s'échauffent et s'est dit tiens
je vais aller voir tonton c'est vrai que
ses cousines crois en fait pour moi
c'était super je suis né en afrique du
sud avec un père qui me donnait un bon
bazin bonne éducation et qui me donnait
des ailes pour partir pour voler
plusieurs aventuriers votre papa aussi
il était joueur de rugby de la fac c'est
sud il était professeur la nuit
universités il avait l'âme d'un
aventurier et puis ils savaient très
bien qu'ils pouvaient pas me garder à la
maison j'ai eu une seule règle c'était
un 6 heures du soir je dois être à la
maison
ah ouais et puis à 300 kilomètres
c'était parce que en fait j'ai eu deux
autres jeux tv à mon papa et puis pour
la première fois je disais mon papa mais
coup tu vas aller visiter mes cousins et
puis j'ai eu des gens qui habitaient à
10 km et à 3 300 km tandis que je suis
allé visiter ce sera votre à six heures
du soir j'étais pas à la maison mauve
mon père qui appelle son frère en dix
ans
mike était là ne l'était pas là et puis
savez très bien que tu avais tiré 3 j'ai
essayé d'y aller et au repas tapas
réussite est revenu non non il est venu
me prend longue la route et puis après
l'a dit mais ça il faut préparer il faut
s'entraîner tu peux pas juste parti
comme ça ou huit ans et puis c'était
deux mois après qu'on a fait
vrai ou faux
avant de partir d'afrique du sud pour
explorer le monde mike a offert tout ce
qu'ils possèdent des maisons piscine
voiture à ses amis vrai ou faux
on se doit et ce qu'il fait mais c'est
vraiment c'est incroyable ça aussi ouais
mais j'ai une petite idée
vitraux bien gagner ma vie et puis avait
un moment que que j'ai eu cette
sentiment que je suis devenu prise une
prisonnière de ma vie et puis j'ai
décidé de tout ce que j'ai eue de
données et d'avoir la liberté de donner
un truc une maison pour ya pensé vous
l'a dit à des amis ou à compliquer j'ai
eu beaucoup d'amis abc sûr je resterai
vrai ou faux après une expédition au
pôle nord et au pôle sud
il tente une expédition au pôle emploi
bien en pwm ike a été dans les forces
spéciales niveau c'est vraiment j'étais
dans la force spéciale de l'afrique du
sud j'ai fait trois ans la guerre en
angola dans les forces spéciales en
afrique du sud
vous avez fait la guerre en béton à mi
vie d'un bébé angola mozambique pendant
les russes et essayer de rentrer en
afrique du sud
et puis on était en fait financé par les
etats-unis parce qu'on faisait la guerre
comptent renard la guerre froide contre
les russes et puis moi je t'ai dit seul
qui à rentrer vivant deux de mes petites
section et puis je pense que parce que
je voulais pas partir pour faire la
guerre je voulais survivre la guerre les
autres partis pour faire la guerre et
puis je pense que ces deux montagnes
mondiale qui est complètement différent
vrai que c'est vrai soit tu partes pour
survire vos tu partes pour faire la
guerre vrai ou faux
mike considère greta tanberg comme sa
fille spirituelle non il la soutient pas
directement
il a déclaré fin janvier c'est des
ridicules de penser que tout le monde
doit arrêter de vivre et éteindre la
lumière greta doit faire attention parce
qu'elle va en confrontation avec tron
faut trouver une solution plutôt que de
faire la guerre moi je pense que c'est
important aujourd'hui pas de faire la
guérilla sûr quand on parle
d'environnement et tout ça s'est fait
tout seul il faut les avoir d'abord être
ensemble c'est vrai vrai ou faux selon
mike les hommes sont mieux adaptés à la
survie que les femmes il faut selon lui
les femmes seraient plus adaptées à la
survie ah ouais ça c'est à 100% c'est
vrai il nourrir leurs enfants
on va juste tirer un coup est parti
[Rires]
vous connais bien en tout cas quel sens
moi nous y est
merci mais on était bien la balle je te
sens pas quand tu dormais vrai ou faux
mike a permis à l'équipe de football
magne de gagner une coupe du monde
alors et alors c'est quoi ça il a tout
fait lui c'est un truc de fou
ça veut dire moi enfin vrai faux sur moi
il ya deux questions de métro sur lui
c'est des trucs de ouf c'est vrai parce
que tu as été coach sportif et mental de
l'équipe d'allemagne en 2014 80 gagner
des coupes du monde d'après j'étais avec
l'équipe dambre de criquets l'afrique de
sud en rupture pure s'est fait mes
études
mes études étaient dans la psychologie
du sport et des ordures sportif qu'il a
et écoute sur le dakar l'équipe de
cricket de londres ont encore pour les
équipes de rugby mike non c'est pas un
mythe
voyez pas j'ai que ça à faire des
maillots est ici on n'a que ça à faire
dire des conneries mais toi tu es venu
il a une vie de dingue
enfin moi je me pose la question je me
dis mais comment vous allez trouver un
mec à la hauteur c'est comme en valeur
c'est facile vous êtes vous êtes vous
êtes fiancée donc célibataire c'est le
seul homme dans ma vie ça fait à vue
sans rigoler quand on perd c'est mike
horn juillet à la maison
je
l'américain andy roddick a dominé souli
lui au travail
[Applaudissements]
son père il est comme ça il en crée des
bords en partie que lui des soul y aura
deux mois de temps te faire alors mais
c'est non mais c'est dur non
sérieusement c'est compliqué oui très
compliqué toi tu cherches un aventurier
tu cherches ou pas du tout je pense que
je cherche l'opposé de mon père c'est
vrai cette les mondiaux
[Applaudissements]
les phares ils montrent trois marchés
nippons glycémie il est pas là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tout cela ici c'est bon althusser
clooney de ton père je pense que tu vas
trouver
je suis si content mon père je peux rien
tu auras du mal à l'opposé la 3e manche
où l embarras du bâton franchement c'est
vrai ou faux mike horn est fan de
valérie bénaïm wii et wii et wii et wii
il la suit sur un stade ce soir il y
avait un départ à moustache celui-ci a
été magnifique c'est bon moi je pense
qu'il faut il faut sourire les gens mais
quand je suis loi de la maison groupe
pendant oui moi je sais pas moi quand
j'ai parlé d'une nouvelle auto nord qui
arrive que les jours et puis quand tu
rentres
et puis tout pour nouveau tact et des
jaune et noir ce qu'ils font c'est long
et c'est là où tu vois qu'il n'ya pas
grand chose qui change mais je sais que
c'est vrai o mine de rien assez sérieuse
qui dit parce qu' il doit partir des six
mois d un angle il reverdit franchement
ça pas changé c'est vrai il ya beaucoup
qui changent mais pas aussi vite qu'on
croit des gens change pas énormément
mais vrai ou faux mike a perdu une
partie de ses doigts à cause du froid
c'est vrai lors d'une expédition ses
doigts au jury qu'il a réussi à les
décoller en les mettant dans l'eau à 37
degrés mais comme il s'est rendormi
derrière les doigts ou geôle à nouveau
c'est en fait c'est comme quand tu tues
mettre la viande de deux congélateurs et
tu le sors pour le gêner après tu peux
part au nouveau le congénères à c'est
fini et ça c'est les mêmes choses avec
c'était tellement fatiguée et qu'elle je
m'endormais puis après ses déconvenues
qu'on le dit que vous avez perdu
le groupe vaudois et ses trois questions
à choix attendre encore 2 tu peux faire
comme ça dans mon spectacle applaudi
comme ça non mais si l'on va pas se
faire chier avec ça c'est vrai que ça va
tu peux de curer le nez avec celui-là
faire lutte mais faire du stop qui
tresse le pousser le petit doigt tu es
tranquille non mais sans déconner tu
peux tout faire
regarde un maître koné ouais j'ai 14
c'est plus cher à la dégager
[Applaudissements]